ladies and gentlemen straight from set
in Toronto Canada where he's been
wrangling the most unruly group of super
villains ever put to celluloid please
give a huge Comicon welcome to director
David
Thank You Asia for having us we were
just shooting last night in Toronto but
we had to come down because we had to
come in and report in the hall H because
you guys run this [ __ ] okay we're making
this movie for you okay this DC Comics
[ __ ] right here it's all about cannon
it's all about being faithful to the
source material you guys know who you
are
and you know what you want you're going
to freaking get it with this show okay
and all this you know good versus evil
shit's kind of played out right now it's
time for bad versus evil right it's
about time for a movie about bad guys
and who's got the best bad guys out
there DC Comics best villains ever now
I'm not trying to start no you know East
Coast West code feud with Marvel Comics
now but hey someone's got to say the
truth alright now I got a little little
footage I want to show you guys we've
been working really hard unfortunately a
lot of people with iPhones have been
running around grabbing it so it's a
little something I found on the internet
that I'd like to show you you guys want
to meet the cast
all right let me get them out here
presenting Catan character the Hara
Slipknot out of date
enchantress card uh LaVon
diablo journalist
gillich rock on why logic
yep boomerang hi Courtney Colonel Rick
Flagg joking man watch out for this next
one Amanda Waller Viola Davis
Harley Quinn Margot Robbie
and the man who cannot miss Will Smith
dad shot
all right that's not a bit thanks for
having us guys we got to go back to work
want to say something hey listen the
Suicide Squad we've been in Toronto this
group right here we are bringing out
something that is absolutely fantastic
and and stunning and this guy right here
David Ayer is the absolute truth he is
making something you are brother love
David Ayer we'll see you all next year
Suicide Squad everybody seriously one
more time for the suicide that wasn't
even working outside I am
Oh
thank you guys thank you
you